well I don't think that we want to look
to them as an example of what they're
doing right they and India have relied
even more than we do on coal to supply
their energy and coal produces even more
carbon dioxide per unit of energy
achieved then oil does so that that's
something that's not something that we
want to follow in fact we need to work
with China and India to persuade them
not to use coal or if they do use coal
to use environmentally friendly
coal-burning technologies which you know
which we're not even using sufficiently
in this country sokol is not a route
that we want to go and we don't want
them to use that because the planet will
really be in jeopardy if they continue
to do that what troubles me about China
and India is that they are going on in
automobile buying spree as their rising
middle class goes out and the first
thing why they want to do is buy a car
now you know it's very hard for us in
this country to say no cars we can have
cars you can have cars because that's
going to increase the pressure on world
petroleum supplies until we start doing
something about our own car addiction
and obviously we're not doing anything
about that so they look at us they see
our TV shows are Hollywood movies and
they say cars that's the good life
that's the American Way of life we want
that too and and they're going out and
buying cars like crazy China is becoming
the world's number two auto market after
the United States they are expected to
have hundreds of millions of new cars on
the road over the next 25 years this
will be a disaster and that's what's
driving their their huge increase in
demand
for petroleum it's it's their increase
in car ownership and India is following
along and as they buy cars they need
more petroleum and because neither China
nor India has large domestic reserves of
petroleum they have to go out and get it
from the same sources of sources of
supply as the United States and here's
where the problem lies and I've alluded
to this earlier they they are especially
China competing with the United States
in this geopolitical struggle for
influence and the oil-producing areas
just as the United States is trying to
ensure access to supplies in places like
China and the purge I'm sorry just as
the United States seeks to obtain
sources of supply in troubled areas like
Africa and the caspian sea basin in
Central Asia so is China and just as we
try to cement our ties with governments
friendly governments in those areas with
supplies of arms China is doing likewise
and they're competing with us there's a
arms competition that goes along with
the pursuit of oil and this is the sort
of thing that I would call the new great
game like the great game that led up to
World War one and has me very worried
you